AS WE GO TO
YOU ARE NEXT GAME, I'VE GOT A
BAD FEELING ABOUT THIS.
HOWEVER -- GOOD NEWS, EVERYONE,
IT'S AFTER MIDNIGHT WHICH
MEANS ONLY 329 DAYS UNTIL
STAR WARS: THE FORCE AWAKENS
OPENS, AND TRIES TO LIVE UP TO
OUR IMPOSSIBLY HIGH EXPECTIONS.
IN RELATED NEWS OF THE WARS,
CNET IS REPORTING THAT DISNEY
DECIDED TO NOT USE GEORGE
LUCAS'S IDEA FOR THE NEW
TRIOLOGY.
-- LEAVING A MAN WHO SOLD HIS
INTELLECTUAL PROPERTY FOR OVER
4 BILLION DOLLARS TO FEEL
KIND OF BUMMED OUT ABOUT IT.
WITH GEORGE'S TRACK RECORD WITH
EPISODES ONE THROUGH THREE IN
MIND, I WOULD LIKE YOU TO GIVE
ME AS MANY OTHER REJECTED
GEORGE LUCAS IDEAS.
LET'S PUT 60 SECONDS ON THE
CLOCK AND BEGIN.
RENE.
>> LUKE AND LEIA ARE ZAPPED
WITH A FORGET RAY AND --
>> Chrs: AND FINALLY CLOSE THE
DEAL.
>> YEAH.
>> Chris: YEAH, POINTS.
ALL RIGHT.
RORY.
>> FOUR MORE SONS ON TATWIN.
>> Chris: POINTS.
EMILY.
>> ONE WHOLE MOVIE DEDICATED
TO CP 3 O'S ONE MAN SHOW.
>> Chris: POINTS.
EMILY.
>> FULL FRONTAL CHEWBACCA.
>> Chris: POINTS.
RORY.
>> TWO WORDS, RAPPING YODA.
>> Chris: I AGREE WITH YOU.
RENE.
>> JUST A LOT MORE ON THE TRADE
EMBARGO STUFF.
>> Chris: YES, ABSOLUTELY. OF
COURSE.
POINTS.